it's a tremendously emotional experience
it has been since we began shooting this
fourth season and I know we'll be at the
end of this night it's a moment in my
life that is profound and prolific rami
malek is feeling bittersweet the actor
was joined by his girlfriend Lucy
Boynton and his mr. robot co-stars in
New York City on Tuesday at the premiere
for the fourth and final season of the
hit USA Network drama series finales are
very difficult and if I may be so bold
as to say I think we nailed it it is a
very fulfilling and cathartic ending
what you're about to do is crossing a
line for that don't you think with mr.
robot coming to an end
Rami shared the sentimental gift creator
Sam s mail gave to him to commemorate
his Emmy winning role you know you put
together a the collection of all the CDs
that Elliott uses to compile all the all
the nasty people who have done the world
wrong and framed them for me with the
photo of the two of the actors next
project he's starring as a villain in
the upcoming James Bond movie no time to
die he opened up to et about how surreal
it was to step on the set and be part of
the iconic franchise I had an
extraordinary time it is phenomenal
every time you get to go to set and you
see those three numbers 0:07 on every
piece of paper on every badge on every
stage it's extraordinary to be part of
that legacy in that history
and I cannot wait for you guys to see
that one as well
[Music]